molars investigation notes several
instances where President Trump
pressured his top aides to lie or
mislead one day after the president
fired FBI director James Comey White
House press secretary Sarah Sanders told
reporters that Comey no longer had the
confidence of mr. Trump and other
people's bipartisan members of Congress
made it clear that they had lost
confidence in director coming and most
importantly the rank and file of the FBI
had lost confidence in their director I
can speak to my own personal experience
I've heard from countless members of the
FBI that are grateful and thankful for
the president's decision according to
Muller's report Sanders told
investigators at the phrase countless
members of the FBI was quote a slip of
the tongue we spoke with the president's
chief spokeswoman a short time ago you
repeated the claims slip of the tongue
several times what exactly did you mean
to say because you appeared to be
reading so you you appeared to be
reading those comments on several
occasions what you mean to say look I'm
acknowledged that the word countless was
a slip of the tongue but it's no secret
that a number of FBI both current and
former agreed with the president's
decision let's not forget that James
Comey was a disgraced leaker who
authorized spine into the Trump campaign
he brought a tremendous amount of
politicizing to the FBI and undermines
the own agency that he was supposed to
be in charge of and leading it was one
of the best decisions that the president
ever made to get rid of him and I'm
thankful that the president is a
president is supported by law
enforcement across this country and that
most law enforcement are not like James
Comey who turned out to be a dirty cop
and has shown time and time again day
after day that the president made the
exact right decision and getting rid of
him and putting somebody else in charge
of the FBI Sarah let me ask you this you
say it was just one word the reason
obviously this is important as you have
a unique position in the system to tell
the truth you say it was one word but
the Muller report says Sanders
acknowledged speaking about this
sentence and this claim of people at the
FBI Sanders ignol
that her comments were not founded on
anything that's not one word that's
saying you know that was actually
actually those were molars words that
they weren't founded on anything what I
said other is in the heat of the moment
that was what I said that it was in the
heat of the moment meaning it wasn't a
scripted thing it was something that I
said and which is why that one word has
become a big deal but the big takeaway
here is that the sentiment is a hundred
percent accurate
the FBI is a better place without James
Comey himself and he undermined the
agency that he was supposed to be in
charge of operation and nothing could be
more dangerous than that in the in the
totality of the 448 page reports there
are a number of instances one of which
the president talks to the White House
Counsel and asked him to remember
something differently than the White
House Counsel remembered it
in the course of your time at the White
House has the president ever asked you
to say something that you not knew not
to be true the president isn't asking
people to to break the law isn't asking
them to do anything that is dishonest if
the president wants to fire somebody he
does you've seen him do it if it works
service isn't a president who's afraid
to go against the system he's not a
president that's afraid to step out and
speak out that's not the question for
someone or something he's gonna state
that that inserted on the front end so
you're saying the president has never
asked you to say anything you knew not
to be true correct and he's also never
asked me to break the law and when the
president wants to do something and make
a decision he does it he's not somebody
who sits around and Ponder's I think
that you guys have seen that day in and
day out
one minute you're running stories that
the staff can't control them the next
minute everyone's saying thank God the
staff could control them you don't get
to have it both ways well in their
mother report they do say thank god this
staff could control them because there
were a couple of times that he wanted to
do something that would be so egregious
it's very specific the Moller report
says the president's efforts to
influence the investigation were mostly
unsuccessful but that's largely because
the persons who surrounded the president
declined to carry out his orders or
accede to it
and on this question of telling aides to
say something that isn't so he asked his
White House lawyer and the language they
use in the report is kind of amusing it
said that the White House lawyer quote
refused to recede from his recollections
which is to say he didn't back down all
I can say to the American people if you
haven't read the Muller report on this
holiday weekend you should pick it up
because it's very revealing four hundred
and forty eight pages yeah a little a
little troubling